we got to pull up this story this is big
this is i mean
this is stupid probably not going to go
anywhere but nbc news reports house
votes to raise minimum age to buy
semi-auto automatic rifles at 21. the
provision is poised to be included in a
larger legislative package set for a
final house vote wednesday night so i i
think that's what they did already
didn't they or is this uh okay so this
is what was what was passed right it's
not it's not just
the uh raising the age of 1921 which is
so insanely unconstitutional there's no
way that that survives but it also
addresses 3d printed guns the tracking
of untraceable guns
is something going on
hot action i don't know
we talked we did talk about the fed so
oh so
something's going on yeah
it's always whenever luke is here so go
check it out
i'll make sure everything okay you guys
continue first time we got squatted luke
was talking and then like the police
just come in look i'm gonna be so pissed
off i gotta spend the night in jail
tonight
so so we have this article we're talking
about the uh the bill hey by the way
real fast uh my buddy uh joshua carlton
texted me that he's watching he said he
loves you so oh cool appreciate that
josh pretty serious what's happening
mentioned um it's it's like it's it's
yeah yeah so
oh
so apparently there's something going on
there are some friendly neighborhood
cops who are going to be swinging by and
checking everything out for us
and hopefully everything will be good so
this is a
text message i think they got saying
that something suspicious is happening
here they're going to come and check and
make sure everything's okay so it's
basically a swatting again basically
yeah so but we got our we got our
security guy here he's going to meet
them cool yeah so we we've uh
it's a good thing we have guns
make up guns yeah i have a i have a
katana behind me and it's a good thing
we have security and a good thing that
we have a relationship with the local
police that's right so
so this is number nine i think we're the
with a bomb squad show card i know we're
about we're really close to that free
yogurt yeah
really close to a free yogurt anyway
sorry for uh ditching i had to step out
oh no no i mean it happens i assumed
it's serious if it's going to be
happening so but but what are they
coming in or what um i think they're
just going to sweep they're going to
check make sure to make sure
everything's good i'm sure everything's
fine there's been nothing suspicious
actually we know what the message was
that was sent or something yeah so wow
yeah so
yeah i can't say too much about what
we've done for security
but i would think i would say we're
actually well above secure at this point
i'm not super worried about this stuff
yeah it's just it can be disruptive i
guess so there you go everybody thanks
for hanging out it just ha ha ha
actually i i kind of feel like this
sounds a little bit more than a swatting
you know what i mean yeah so this is a
little
interesting a little more casual i want
to hear more details on it because i
guess it was a text message that was
sent and i'm not sure text to who yeah
i'll say who's getting a text message
well look look look guys yeah no worries
considering what just happened in
maryland we are like we're about what 45
minutes away from where that guy showed
up at kavanaugh's he flew from
california with weapons planning to
kidnap and assassinate brett kavanaugh
i can't say i'm surprised we're not that
far away so there's creepy weirdos
but so let's talk about this there's
also reports of protests happening
outside of kavanaugh's place right now
yeah i don't know it's crazy which is
yeah here's the thing though really all
of this boils down to everybody talks
about it being you know a gun issue it's
not a gun issue i think joe rogan
probably said it best you know we have a
mental health issue described you know
um
kind of couched into a gun issue
disguised as a gun issue now yeah sure
having a mental health issue describe
disguise as a gun issue is a problem
however really this is a value of human
life issue we no longer value someone
else as ha as just a human being you
have value just because i believe you're
creating the image of god so for me you
have value just in that alone we may
disagree fundamentally on a lot of
social issues and maybe even religious
maybe moral issues however you still
have value as a human being and most
people don't have that anymore that's
right part of the desperation of 1928
that i brought up early weimar germany
late vomit germany early nazi germany
when they started to dehumanize other
people probably because they were
wealthy and that they didn't the people
that were desperate weren't wealthy
anymore and they were they were hating
on the wealth and so
desperation breeds you know desperate
actions like i need that food why do you
get that food why were you born into
family that can have food when i right
but for a long time in america i think
that we got to a point where it wasn't
so much that we were we maybe were going
that way but it wasn't so much that we
were needing food it was that i liked
the jordans that you had
and that's a different value system
altogether as a society you know for us
to be wrapped around that kind of stuff
that's a problem because i think that's
where we start not valuing a human being
anymore
and i think that's a very dangerous path
for us to go down
you're talking about like material yeah
well and it's not even immaterialism
it's just everything's so superficial
you're not caring about a person and so
we have to get back to the point as a
society because i believe i firmly
believe
that americans when we're united we're
unstoppable we've shown that over and
over again we showed it after 9 11 we
showed it in world war 1 and world war
ii we showed it over and over again
but we've got to get to a point and i
hate that it takes tragedy for it to
happen we have to get to a point where
we are looking at each other no longer
as these different buckets that we put
ourselves in this identity politics but
because you're a human being you have
value to me i was with it back there we
were talking i was talking about uh
humans like in crowds and what what do
the birds think of us when they fly
overhead and look at us like at a con a
rock concert with 20 000 people all
moving in unison and they were like uh
my girlfriend was telling me like they
must think we are the most terrifying
species on earth because when we form
when formation occurs and we come
together
it's uh insanely unstoppable like the
power of the human being right and
i for better or worse i think of the
nazi the crowds out when hitler's giving
a speech and you see ten thousand nazis
all like marching in secession like it
can be horribly manipulated but also
because you use it to inspire yeah and i
think that's that's my hope my people
talk about oh well you're going to be a
politician like my my prayer honestly is
i never become a politician my my prayer
is i become a statesman someone who
focuses on the next generation a
politician only focuses on maintaining
power they focus on the next election
cycle a statesman is only focusing on
the next generation and we have to think
long term like that what is this going
to do for the next generation of people
if we start thinking like that again i
think that provides hope what are your
what are your tactics like your
humanization tactics when you when you
when you personally seek to humanize
you know crowds or people you disagree
with so a lot of it comes back down to
my faith it really does you know and and
i understand that people are searching
for things um and i think a lot of times
we we misunderstand what we're searching
for but understanding and valuing a
person just because they have value
because they're creating the image of
god to me that's that's such a great way
for me to be able to relate to somebody
because i can cut through all the other
stuff if we disagree i don't care what
it is abortion police defunding the
police we call it whatever it is second
amendment i can still value you as a
person and that is very important for us
to get to when you're at war oh do you
want to no i was just finished that way
when you were in in the middle east and
did it did that happen with the enemy
combatants was there a sense of
humanization there or did you have to
just
pretend like it wasn't there or what was
that like a little bit of both honestly
going i remember going over the first
time um it was a very difficult thing
for me to process um because if what i
believe is true and i believe it is you
know as far as my faith um then
i believe that every single person over
there that their life ended they were
separated from a guy who loves them
forever so that was a very difficult
thing for me to process and get to a
spot to where i was okay with but once
you're over there and you're operating
you're simply you're performing
with the operation you're protecting
your brother beside you it's a
completely different thing altogether
so do you think that social media has
played like the biggest role in
dehumanizing other people oh yeah it's
so easy to stay behind a keyboard and
scream and shout at each other and you
know type in all caps if you're really
mad
but it's but it but it translates into
the real world in ways that many of us
didn't think were gonna happen we kept
saying twitter wasn't real life right
but then that hatred people feel they
bring to the real world you're right
there's this video we can't show it in
full but it's uh went up at 8 12
secret service takedown of a protester
during potus motorcade from fox la
this is one of the craziest videos i've
seen i don't know if it's actually a
secret service takedown there's a woman
who walks into the street
in the middle of the motorcade of the
president bull horning she get there and
the cops run up and slam her to the
ground and she attacks the cops well
that's dumb
i mean dumb yeah crazy yeah it's like
people are turning into zombies
that's the thing that's my thing even
with the mass shootings and stuff like
that is you know these people want to be
memorialized forever
even if it's for something bad they want
to be known at this time and the
corporate media according to many
scientific studies now actually promotes
and inspires these mass shootings
because of the way that they cover these
events the way that they show the
picture of the individual then they the
way that they make him infamous the way
that they talk about the manifesto the
details that they give about them this
essentially creates more mass killers
there's a reason
when someone runs onto a stadium floor
during a sports ball game that that the
the the cameras don't don't point to him
because they know it's going to inspire
other people to do so the same thing
happens with mass shooters so if you
really wanted to stop it we would be
covering this differently but but they
don't msnbc and all these other
corporate media organizations are
literally creating copycat killers uh i
agree and spurring on similar situations
this is why buffalo was so close to the
situation in texas and there might be
even another one with how they've been
reporting on the texas situation with
all you have to do is again stop
focusing on this monster start focusing
on the victims and you would not only
shift the narrative but you would stop
future
shootings and mass murderers you
actually start humanizing exactly
absolutely and and that's that's what
the corporate media should be doing if
they really wanted to to to stop all
these you know very violent events they
would stop promoting these violent
murderers and giving them the attention
that they want well they don't want to
stop them they want the click but
honestly i actually think that it's you
would get better ratings if you simply
focused on the emotion of it
on the fact that you focus on the
victims i think you get a lot more
engagement from people but instead they
focus on the opposite you were also
saying how it's like people want to be
hurt this is their way of being heard or
seen and i wonder if if someone is
arrested for an attempted mass shooting
or mass shooting maybe that but they're
still alive if we should
interview them and let them speak to be
heard because no then
then more people will do it but you'll
also see it on tv but you can see how
crazy it is as well if we hide it then
it's like you call them a monster for
what they are like the people who do
these shootings are monsters yes but
giving them attention means more crazy
people don't name them yeah don't even
name them don't show them that's not it
that's not it let me tell you guys a
story i love this story it's about 11
years ago i'm hanging out i was in
virginia actually
and uh 4chan had an operation called
operation king kong that's all it was
they were watching earth cam which is
live streams around the world
someone pulled up times square and they
said can we use the collective power of
the internet to knock over this street
cone
in the times square camera next to i
think it was tg tgif was a little street
cone and they said okay we've got the
meme up we've got the page up
let's knock it over
people kept trying crazy things someone
ordered a pizza and told the pizza guy
and the pizza guy's like i don't know
what's going on you see the guy in the
bike right up with the pizza everyone's
spamming like crazy in the in the thread
like he's gonna do it he's gonna no he
left then finally at the end of the day
some some people are walking by some
young guys and then all of a sudden they
walk they walk past it stop
walk backwards like rewinding and then
knock the cone over and then wave to the
camera and everybody's cheering saying
like we did it
then
a woman walks by picks the cone up pulls
a crown out of her purse and puts it on
top of the cone because it was operation
king cone
the point is
people are just trying to move the
needle in any way possible these are
people who are bored they're lonely they
feel like they don't matter at all
anything that gets them any kind of
acknowledgement it doesn't need to be
their name it needs to be the fact that
we talked about the tragedy period is
what they want and they get it even if
you don't show them they sit back and
they watch afterwards saying all of this
because of me
i don't know how you stopped it
i think what we need is i'll tell you
the simple answer is we need dads yep a
lot of the i think the family the common
profile is no dad right yep ssris as
well heavy yes particularly in many of
these particular cases uh self-harm
self-abuse uh mental health issues also
a very big one um and but how much of
that stems from the family unit too yeah
absolutely we've seen it like the family
university decades exactly and the
pharmaceuticals is no joke dude sure i
don't know how do you quantify it though
how do you know how much damage adderall
is doing to 13 year olds right how can
you i'm asking a genuine question can't
i mean you got to look at how much
the the use of it's gone up i mean it's
through the roof
from where it used to be so you're
having everybody and it's i think it's
partially parents too you know we as
parents we got to make sure we have to
be much more hesitant to um put our kids
on stuff that we don't understand
you know even even vaccines for crying
out loud i mean so and the reason i say
that so for my son my oldest son um you
know i got him a flu shot this was a few
years back and i mean he had a small
seizure after the flu shot this was long
before you know covered and everything
else and so it made us go cool we're
going to have a pause on that for a
while till we figure out what's going on
but make sure crazy conspiracy theorists
yeah well it is what it is i'm going to
do everything i have to do to protect my
kids i mean we had the the drummer from
a former drummer from the offspring
right he had guillain-barre syndrome so
they were like you we don't think you
should get this vaccine he got kicked
out of the band for it right they were
like oh sorry we can't work with you
it's like you'd think 17 years would
earn you some loyalty but some people
are just they don't care about that
stuff no yeah when a kid's on
amphetamines you'd be like yeah i'm not
going to get my kid amphetamines but
then all of a sudden it's like oh pfizer
and my doctor said it was okay now i
guess i'll give my kid in like just
cause federally what do we do because
that's where my head goes now right with
remove some of the protections from some
of these companies that they're
protected they can do anything they want
to do without any kind of recourse no
liability same thing with that same
thing with your facebook and twitter and
everything else
me as an individual i can't sue them
you know but we should be able to yeah
you get hurt you you know it doesn't
matter if your job forced you to do this
right if if the media told you to do
this if the government told you to do
this if your doctor told you to do this
you get hurt
you're the one who's going to be
responsible paying for your own medical
bills no one else is going to be
covering or helping you in in any way
shape or form so so you know biden likes
to talk about how the gun industry is
unaccountable not liable
only industry yeah the only industry
well that's not the case here obviously
with all the information that we have in
front of they have more accountability
than probably any other industry right
now i've never understood why the big
pharmacy
the big pharmaceutical you call them a
mafia i've never understood why these
people who literally make things that
you inject into your body and absorb
into your bloodstream have zero
accountability what is going on there i
think it's because they feel like if
something does go wrong which it's bound
to eventually they'll get sued into
oblivion and then they can no longer
function and the value of
pharmaceuticals is that modern
medicine's a miracle absolutely the
problem is it's the business of medicine
that they're incentivized to have people
be ill so that they buy their medicine
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time